ah
en la capacidad para hacer trabajo y
debería ser la mayor de las aspiraciones
individuales de la familia de una
comunidad y de un país tener los
recursos y los mecanismos necesarios
para generar esa energía y tener el
privilegio del disfrute pleno de los
recursos y de la actividad productiva
que ella genera en el caso de puerto
rico nosotros tenemos una economía y una
operación dependiente de combustibles
fósiles es una operación basada en la
explotación de recursos naturales no
renovables es la explotación de
diferentes sociedades y que tiene
grandes implicaciones
nefastas en el ambiente en el caso
nuestro dependemos de unas centrales que
generan esta energía de líneas de
transmisión y distribución para que
eventualmente esa energía pueda llegar
al hogar a la industria al negocio a la
escuela donde se realizan las diferentes
actividades productivas pero ese modelo
basado en combustibles fósiles de
petróleo carbón gas natural en la
primera década de este milenio
representó la pérdida de más de 22 mil
millones de dólares en simplemente pagar
por el combustible así que gran parte de
la actividad productiva del país del
trabajo que se realiza lo perdemos no
tenemos el disfrute pleno porque va
precisamente a pagar estos combustibles
que no tenemos yo vengo de adjuntas
vengo del campo de una comunidad que
está organizada ya por cerca de 40 años
donde romper las dependencias las
diferentes tipos de dependencias
a mental y hemos roto el modelo de
dependencia económica produciendo
nuestro propio café tenemos proyectos de
educación para los jóvenes que son
nuestra prioridad en el tema de las
comunicaciones con nuestra radio
comunitaria manejamos y protegemos dos
bosques del estado el bosque del pueblo
el bosque la olimpia y operamos hace ya
20 años con autosuficiencia energética
generamos la energía usando el sol en el
lugar donde la necesitamos de manera
limpia y renovable pero imagínense
ustedes poder ir a una escuela a ser
educado como el bosque escuela lo limpia
donde el currículo no está escrito en un
libro sino que el currículo es
precisamente la naturaleza misma es el
bosque el que nos da las lecciones sobre
por qué debemos proteger nuestras
cuencas hidrográficas el valor del agua
para producir energía eléctrica la
importancia de los hongos en la
descomposición el salón es donde usted
puede aprender con fuentes
limpias iluminación natural donde el
paisaje provoca que usted puede a través
de la observación levantar diferentes
tipos de inquietudes y aprender a través
del método científico y dentro de esa
casa común y la manera en que nosotros
nos acercamos a los recursos naturales y
la forma en que generamos energía el
problema es que ha tenido consecuencias
hemos golpeado hemos impactado hemos
comprometido la seguridad de nuestro
planeta generando emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero que provocan cambio
climático y ese cambio climático quizás
la mejor manera de verla en nuestro
entorno es lo que está ocurriendo por
ejemplo con el tema de huracanes en el
caribe y los huracanes son eventos
naturales los tenemos en ciertas
temporadas el problema no es el huracán
el problema es como cambio climático
está provocando que sean tormentas más
grandes porque hay más calor en el
sistema que haya más humedad por el
proceso de evaporación entonces los
eventos
son más intensos eventos de lluvia más
intensos significan que lluvias van a
provocar deslizamientos y en el caso de
puerto rico tras el paso del huracán
maría más de 100.000 eventos no 100
100.000 eventos de deslizamientos se
registraron vía satelital en nuestra
isla
y cuando usted piensa en que un grado
centígrado es insignificante mire sepa
que dos representan que usted está
saludable versus tener fiebre un grado
centígrado adicional investigadores en
la universidad de princeton han
establecido que pueden provocar la
aceleración añadirle hasta 18 millas por
hora a las fuerzas de los vientos en
estas tormentas entonces no estamos
hablando de algo insignificante estamos
hablando de una agravar unas tormentas
que comprometen nuestra infraestructura
energética que en el caso de la pobreza
representa entonces que nuestros
hermanos pierdan sus casas que pierdan
sus techos por no tener hogar seguro
pero en el caso de romper las
dependencias y de pensar en un futuro
diferente casa pueblo que pudo
sostener los vientos huracanados del
huracán maría pudo abrir al día
siguiente y por operar con energías
renovables por poder generar energía en
el lugar donde la necesitamos de pronto
al día siguiente estábamos de vuelta
ofreciendo servicios a nuestra comunidad
y habían necesidades como en todo puerto
rico y gente de pronto fue llegando a
conectar sus máquinas de terapias
respiratorias a recargar sus equipos y
decidimos entonces orquestrar una
respuesta humanitaria pero para
perseguir un cambio y comenzamos a
distribuir lámparas solares para para
que las familias se pudieran iluminar en
la noche para que aprendieran de
energías renovables luego empezamos a
'aa' a 'aa-' a integrar otros elementos
en el tema energético asociado a la
nutrición fundamental para mantener
nuestra salud y el colapso del sistema
energético entre otras consecuencias del
sufrimiento que vivió nuestro país hubo
una traducción
en miles de muertos un excedente de
hasta tres mil muertos más de lo que
debió haber ocurrido
y si usted piensa no solamente los
muertos piensan los enfermos la gente
que era pre diabética pre hipertensa que
comenzó con comida chatarra un día uno
esperaría verdad después la tormenta una
semana de pronto era un mes dos meses
tres meses cuatro meses entonces el
poder refrigerar los alimentos era
importante y para maría medina era
importante poder operar su máquina de
diálisis peritoneal y entonces empezamos
a energizar lugares donde donde se
requerían necesidades especiales de
salud y maría medina ahora podía recibir
su terapia con sistemas fotovoltaicos
porque tenía el derecho a la energía y
puede ahora generar energía en su hogar
y de esa misma manera en el tema de las
comunicaciones nuestra radio comenzó a
energizar su torre de transmisión
con energía fotovoltaica en el lugar del
consumo y aquí sufrimos gravemente
porque todas las torres de comunicación
en zonas distantes no había combustible
no había acceso no había forma de
energizar las y eso comprometió la
capacidad del país a responder a un
evento natural como está hoy guy qué tal
si usted con la energía configura ahora
a través de una micro red un cine solar
imagínense que usted tengo un cine que
pueda ir al día después y los niños
puedan ir a tener actividades de
aprendizaje en un espacio recobrar
cierta normalidad después de una crisis
como como el paso de un huracán
qué tal aserto ferreterías solares la
primera lección era una pizzería 5
colmados en las zonas rurales que
representan las primeras zonas de de de
usted tener acceso a alimentos y donde
no median los negocios como en la zona
metropolitana ya si usted no tiene
efectivo
ahí está el fiado le dan la comida y se
resuelven después es una dinámica
comercial diferente y esta es la casa
agrícola que ahora es parte de esas
iniciativas de transformar el paisaje
energético de adjuntas hasta el parque
de bomberos ahora en adultas opera con
energía solar y ahí está el centro de
emergencias médicas también para poder
ser autosuficiente energéticamente hoy
mañana y en el futuro cuando tengamos
que enfrentar futuros consecuencias
ambientales esta es la égida la casa de
del hogar de los envejecientes que
también lo hace
que lo puede hacer ahora que puede
generar su energía y satisfacer los
requisitos energéticos para los
servicios que requiere una población
vulnerable como este cualquier propuesta
que esté sobre el país que hable sobre
combustibles fósiles es la mirada del
siglo pasado en la mirada del retraso en
la medida a la explotación y mantener al
país preso como un mercado y no como lo
que estamos haciendo en adjuntas que es
convirtiendo y transformando que la
gente en lugar de consumidores sean
actores y productores de su propia
energía necesitamos un futuro de
autosuficiencia energética estamos
persiguiendo 50 por ciento con sol que
50 por ciento de la demanda energética
de nuestro pueblo la podamos satisfacer
con generación en el lugar donde hace
falta en las casas en nuestros negocios
para el 20 27 para el aniversario el
décimo aniversario del huracán maría 50
que no tengamos la cuenta de los
combustibles fósiles porque el sol
es gratuito de lo global
entonces a lo local donde tenemos que
asumir responsabilidades para cambiar
esta realidad y por la resurrección de
nuestro planeta la insurrección
energética muchas gracias